>>Anjali Kumar: It's lunch time at Google
with Anjali Kumar.
Today our guest is Ahmir "?uestlove" Thompson.
>>Ahmir: Hello
>>Anjali: Well I'm glad you could come by
my desk, because I have a lot of stuff to
do.
And I have a call in a couple of minutes,
so we'll make this quick.
>>Ahmir: OK.
>>Anjali: Do you, I brought you lunch.
I hope you like pickles.
>>Ahmir: Yes.
>>Anjali: You do.
>>Ahmir: I like pickles.
What kind?
>>Anjali: Awesome.
I don't know what it is.
>>Ahmir: Oh, OK, this is a regular New York.
>>Anjali: Oh, I didn't realize, it's a lot
of stuff.
I mean, but there's pickles in there too.
Oh, I have this too.
So we can trade.
[inaudible]
>>Ahmir: Of course, my trainer is not looking
right now so I'm going for the, uh, Ok he's
not looking.
I'm going for these.
>>Anjali: They're awesome, right?
>>Ahmir: I'm not supposed to do this.
>>Anjali: We're gonna start easy.
>>Ahmir: Um-hm.
>>Anjali: Word association.
With top Google search terms.
Are you ready?
First word that comes to your mind?
>>Ahmir: OK.
>>Anjali: OK.
We're on a schedule.
First thing that comes to your mind.
You ready?
>>Ahmir: Fresh air.
>>Anjali: [chuckles] Rebecca Black
[drums play]
>>Ahmir: Um.
>>Anjali: Chick-Fil-A. We don't have time
for this "?uestlove."
Move on.
>>Ahmir: Really?
>>Anjali: OK, Rebecca Black.
I'll give you another chance.
Rebecca Black.
>>Ahmir: Revealer.
>>Anjali: Chick-Fil-A.
>>Ahmir: Sundaes.
>>Anjali: Amoeba.
>>Ahmir: Business management anger.
>>Anjali: Pippa Middledton.
>>Ahmir: Pass.
>>Anjali: OK, so I Googled you, obviously.
>>Ahmir: Um-hm.
>>Anjali: Because we're here at Google.
And there were over one point six million
results.
Did you know that?
>>Ahmir: Really?
>>Anjali: Yeah.
I think the Kardashians have more.
But one point six million.
So I thought we would just go through them
one by one.
>>Ahmir: So you mean, one point six million
people have Googled me?
Or?
>>Anjali: No, no.
One point six million things come up when
I Google your name.
>>Ahmir: Wow.
>>Anjali: Over one point six million.
It's a lot.
>>Ahmir: That means I've done a lot in the
last, almost, 20 years.
>>Anjali: Exactly.
Can we go through them one by one?
I mean, you have time.
>>Ahmir: Sure.
>>Anjali: Ready?
Who would you have lunch with if you weren't
having lunch with me right now at my desk?
>>Ahmir: Most of the time I just eat by myself
and watch old Soul Train episodes in my cave.
I have a cave just like the one that we're
in right now.
>>Anjali: You do?
You have a cubicle?
>>Ahmir: Although, I'm assuming , um.
>>Anjali: Can I come by?
>>Ahmir: Yeah.
It's a cubicle that has turned into my studio.
We recorded the last two Roots albums in a
room probably this size.
>>Anjali: Really?
>>Ahmir: Yeah.
One of the prime reasons why I wanted to visit
here
>>Anjali: Apart from me.
>>Ahmir: No.
Yes.
Especially, yes.
[inaudible]
>>Anjali: Thank you.
>>Ahmir: I religiously check Google doodles
and I compare other countries' Google doodles
and I'm that person that talks to the Google
twitter account like it's a real person.
>>Anjali: Yeah.
>>Ahmir: It's almost like, in what's the movie
where Jim Carey gets to have the power of
God, um.
>>Anjali: Bruce Almighty.
>>Ahmir: Yes.
It was Bruce Almighty.
Thanks for Googling that.
>>Anjali: OK, but.
>>Ahmir: Anyway, my whole point was, um, wait,
why did I even bring up the Bruce Almighty?
[inaudible]
>>Anjali: I have no idea!
[laughter]
>>Anjali: Can you explain the road from the
Grammys to the kitchen.
How did that happen?
>>Ahmir: Oh, it's a great story.
>>Anjali: OK.
Wait.
>>Ahmir: My dear grandmother has itó
[phone rings]
>>Anjali: Sorry.
My phone.
Just one second.
Justó hello?
[music stops]
>>Anjali: Hi.
Yeah.
Mom.
I'm in an interview.
[jazzy music resumes]
>>Anjali: What's the last thing you searched
for?
We already know because it was Bruce Almighty.
Can you slow down the results for me?
Can somebody cue the music for me please?
[soul music plays]
>>Ahmir: That's funny.
>>Anjali: Bruce Almighty.
2003.
I am [inaudible].
>>Ahmir: Yeah.
She's online.
Searching for God.
She needs God in her life.
She's searching.
Bruce.
A movie from 2003.
>>Anjali: I've got a present for you.
It's a little surprise from our, we know you're
a big fan of the Google doodle.
And,
>>Ahmir: How do you know??
>>Anjali: Because you tweet about it.
So one of our team out at Mountain View who's
an amazing doodler and huge "?uestlove" fan,
did this.
>>Ahmir: So I turn 150 years old, this is
going to be my Google doodle?
>>Anjali: I don't know, you tell me.
>>Ahmir: [laughing]
>>Anjali: You like it?
>>Ahmir: I love this.
>>Anjali: OK, so
>>Ahmir: This is everything I love.
Drums.
Prince.
>>Anjali: Yeah.
Hearts.
>>Ahmir: A red heart and a drumstick and a
>>Anjali: I don't know what that is, a chicken
bone?
>>Ahmir: Apparently the letter 'L'.
This is the best thing that ever happened
to me today, man.
>>Anjali: The best thing that ever happened
to you, today.
>>Ahmir: I will cherish this forever.
I mean, thank you.
>>Anjali: That was amazing.
[jazzy music plays]
[Anjali chokes]